JASON SANMIYA: Today
we're going to give you
some compelling
reasons why you should
start thinking about
performance in your games
and VR experiences.
And we're going to show
you some of the tech
that our team has
developed to help you
create high performance games.
But first let me introduce
my good friend and colleague,
Wouter van Oortmerssen.
So Wouter has a background
in game development.
He's worked at Crytek, Maxis,
and also at Gearbox, so one
of my personal favorite
games, Borderlands.
Wouter taught game
programming at the Guildhall,
and he's created
several open source game
engines and languages,
my favorite of which is
the deliciously named Lobster.
Wouter also speaks
six natural languages,
seven if you include the one he
invented when he was a teenager
and that only he and his
little sister understand.
Overall, he's a
lovely fellow and I
recommend getting to know him.
All right?
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
Thank you, Jason.
So let me introduce
Jason to you.
So Jason also has a game
development background,
particularly in animation.
Before he joined
Google, he was working
at Electronic Arts, where his
locomotion system was powering
the Madden and FIFA franchises.
So recently Jason led
our team to create
our most recent sample
game, Zushi, that's
available on the Play Store.
We'll see it later.
And most importantly, I think,
that Jason's stated life
goal is that he wants to acquire
all life's acquired tastes.
So I think you should
join him in that.
JASON SANMIYA: Thanks, Wouter.
Wouter and I work
on a team called
Fun Propulsion Labs at Google.
Our mission is to support
game developers just like you
by creating cross-platform,
open source technology that you
can use in your games.
And not just games
that you're making now.
We also want to
ensure that you're
set up with the right
technology to help you make
great games in the near future.
So today we're going
to talk about 3D games
and virtual reality.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
And why we think they're
going to be increasingly
large blips on your radar.
JASON SANMIYA: Why
they're difficult.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
And finally we're
going to present some technology
that we've created in our team
that we think will help
you succeed in 3D and VR.
JASON SANMIYA:
Along the way we'll
show you some of the
small sample games
that our team has developed
to demonstrate our tech.
For example, this
here, this is Pie Noon.
It's a multiplayer standoff
game but with cherry pies.
It's pretty serious
stuff that we do.
But first and
quickly, why games?
Serious developers make
serious apps, don't they?
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
Well, games are big business.
I mean look at the Play Store.
The majority of revenue from
the Play Store comes from games.
JASON SANMIYA: Yes,
and the game market
is expanding to new
demographics, too.
As you can see here, the
demographic that likes, say,
men screaming with
their mouths open,
that's pretty well served today.
But going forward,
new game genres
are becoming more and
more popular as well.
So entire new
demographics are going
to come online and become
game consumers too.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
But maybe they
just have their mouths
open because they
like the candy in
the adjacent games.
JASON SANMIYA: It is
exactly the same face
I made this morning
when I saw the donuts.
WOUTER VAN
OORTMERSSEN: All right.
So games make money
today, and they're
going to make even
more money tomorrow.
Why do we care
about performance?
Games are pretty simple, no?
JASON SANMIYA: It's true
that many of today's games
are technically simple.
Here's some of my
recent favorite games.
Does anybody
recognize these games?
Just call out the names.
AUDIENCE: Ridiculous Fishing.
JASON SANMIYA:
Ridiculous Fishing.
Of course.
Anyone else?
How about the one in the middle?
That's kind of obscure.
It's called The Guides.
Very odd game
worth checking out.
And on the right
is Pop the Lock.
So all of these games have
wonderful visual aesthetics,
but technically they don't
really tax the hardware.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN: So
games like these should probably
still be optimized
for low end devices
or just to save battery.
But for the most
part, performance
is not going to be on the
radar for these kind of games.
But there are games that
do tax the hardware,
and as game players get used
to these kind of visuals,
they're going to
be expecting them.
JASON SANMIYA: Anyone
know this game?
AUDIENCE: The Wolf Among Us.
JASON SANMIYA: That's right.
The Wolf Among Us
by Telltale Games.
So this game was
released in 2013
on the Xbox, the PlayStation,
Windows, and Mac.
And then soon after, it was
also released on mobile.
So these screenshots
are actually
from the Android version, and
I think they look amazing.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
So mobile hardware
is getting
increasingly powerful.
So console game developers
are increasingly
going to bring these
kind of games to mobile,
and that's exactly
what they're doing.
JASON SANMIYA: For
example, some of my friends
that are still on FIFA
soccer, when they release
FIFA 16 this year, they're
using a lot of the code
that I wrote three years
ago before I joined Google.
And this is code that we
really struggled to make run
on the consoles at the time.
But they just port it
over to mobile devices
and it runs fine.
And in fact, this is
something that a lot
of console developers
really have to do,
because the mobile game
market is growing much faster
than the console and
the PC game market,
so they need to start
bringing over these
console games to mobile.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
And then there
is virtual reality, which is
intrinsically a 3D experience.
So we think that
you're going to see
more and more of these kind
of experiences on mobile
pretty soon, and
less of the examples
that we gave previously.
JASON SANMIYA: Of
course, there's
going to be plenty of both
styles of games, 2D, 3D,
simple, complex.
But still, console
games on mobile
it's going to raise
consumer expectations,
just like Wouter says.
And this means if performance
isn't on your radar today,
it probably will be
in the near future.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
So we're going
to have to start thinking
about performance.
But how much do we have to start
thinking about performance?
What happens when
you get it wrong?
JASON SANMIYA: Good question.
So this game is Tengami.
It's a really
beautiful, smoothly
animated game, the paper craft
world, and it kind of folds
and unfolds like origami as
you go through the world.
It's strangely calming
and kind of zen-like.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN: So
for 3D games like Tengami,
you want to ideally
hit a fixed frame rate
of 30 to 60 frames per second.
When you get
performance problems,
then you're going to
drop frames and that's
going to create stuttering.
Now if your game is mostly
static without too much motion,
you may be able to get away
with a little bit of stuttering.
But if you have smooth
scrolling like Tengami has here,
or a lot of camera motion,
then that stuttering
is going to end up
being pretty jarring.
JASON SANMIYA: And
dropped frames are
even more of a problem in VR.
So for cardboard,
you want to hit
at least 60 frames per second.
You might think, well,
if I hit 59 frames
per second, that's good enough.
But in VR, every dropped frame
is like snagging your eyeball
on a rusty nail.
WOUTER VAN
OORTMERSSEN: So you're
saying that if I had 59
frames per second, that's
like hitting my eyeball
on a rusty nail,
like, once per
second effectively?
JASON SANMIYA: That's exactly
how the math works out.
But in less dramatic
terms, dropping frames
means user fatigue
and discomforts
and potentially even nausea.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
So let's not forget
about the next billion users.
There's like a billion
of them, after all.
JASON SANMIYA: And they're
going to have modern phones,
but they may not be
the fastest phones.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
For example,
the Nexus 6P and the Android
1 are both great phones.
But just because
your game runs great
the Nexus 6P is
not going to mean
it's going to run great on
the next billion Android 1s.
JASON SANMIYA: And even if
you hit 60 frames per second,
it's still worthwhile
considering performance,
because wasted CPU cycles
mean wasted battery.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
And battery
is pretty important to
mobile game players.
JASON SANMIYA: So when you're
playing a simple 2D game
and your phone heats up
like it's a pocket warmer,
that's a good sign that the
developer wasn't prioritizing
performance.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
So you said
that mobile is going to become
more like a console experience.
What does that imply?
JASON SANMIYA: Well,
let's take a look
at how current mobile
game development differs
from current console
game development,
and that might give
us a sense for where
mobile development might go.
So first off, mobile development
teams are quite small.
Console development
teams, on the other hand,
come in all sizes, some
of them quite large.
With a small team you have
to limit your technology.
But with a big team,
your technology stack
is going to be
correspondingly large.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN: So
to put it in a different way,
many of you may be familiar
with the idea of a thin client,
thick server model
that's very common in web
apps and mobile apps.
So what you get, if
you take mobile gaming
and you add
console-style technology,
is you get more of a
thick client, thick server
model where you're doing
intensive rendering, physics,
animation, all
that on the client,
and you're still going to have
a rich server side component.
So that gets pretty complicated.
JASON SANMIYA: Right.
OK, then.
So when we're working with these
more technically complicated
clients, what are some of
the performance problems
that we're going to run into?
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN: So
let's first talk about memory.
Unlike consoles,
you don't really
have a guaranteed amount of
memory on a mobile device.
And unlike PCs, you don't really
have virtual memory either.
So what it means
is that it really
depends on the
situation when Android's
going to tell you that
you've had too much memory.
So the only way to make sure
that your game fits in memory
and stays in memory is use
as little as possible of it.
And there's another good reason.
Memory bandwidth
on mobile devices
is very low compared to
equivalent PC or console
devices.
So you may see a mobile
device, and you go, like, wow,
that thing has eight
cores in it and stuff,
and until you realize that if
those eight cores all start
touching memory, then things
grind to a halt pretty quickly.
JASON SANMIYA: Then there's
the thermal consequences
of using a lot of resources.
Your CPU is going
to get throttled.
So mobile hardware
was designed for apps,
which means they're designed
to wake up, serve the user,
and then idle for a little bit.
When it's idling,
it gives the CPU
some time to dissipate heat.
But games, on the
other hand, are
kind of using the system
evenly at all times.
So this means that the heap can
just kind of build up and build
up until the CPU frequency has
to be throttled back in order
to dissipate it.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
And because you
don't control this throttling,
it kind of has this ping pong
effect on your frame
rate, which is exactly
the kind of thing that's going
to make your VR users nauseous.
JASON SANMIYA: OK.
So we need to hit 60 frames per
second with no dropped frames,
especially when targeting VR.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN: So
that's going to be hard to do
in C++, and frankly, it's
almost impossible in Java.
JASON SANMIYA: Now there's
probably some Java programmers
in here, so it's probably worth
diving into this a little bit.
Maybe you can tell us a little
bit what performance challenges
people see when they
develop games in Java.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
Well, first, of course,
Java's garbage collection.
And garbage collection does not
help you keep a stable frame
rate because the garbage
collector is going
to hit at a particular frame,
give you a very lengthy frame,
and then another frame
is going to be shorter.
That's exactly
what we don't want.
But even besides that, typically
Java code is going to be
slightly slower than the
equivalent C++ code for CPU
stuff like physics, animation,
simulation, that kind of thing.
So even if you can make it work,
even if you can make it fit
somehow, then you're going to
end up burning more battery
and generating more heat
than equivalent C++.
JASON SANMIYA: It's a
really tricky situation.
And it's one that's worth
considering very carefully
because choosing a
language is something
you do at the beginning.
And optimizing your
program for performance
is, unfortunately, something
you tend to do at the end.
So if you get to the
end of your project
and you have a lot of trouble
squeezing out performance
because of the intrinsic
nature of your language,
well, that's a real
sinking feeling.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
And of course,
with C++ you get this
cross-platform nature for free
on mobile and desktop platforms.
JASON SANMIYA:
And cross-platform
is increasingly important as the
games become more complicated.
So writing your game twice
for two different platforms
in two different languages
is a very high cost to that.
OK.
We understand this
is challenging.
C++ is kind of like a
double-barreled shotgun,
but with 1,000 barrels
and they're all pointed
at your foot.
WOUTER VAN
OORTMERSSEN: But that's
where our team comes in.
we're Fun Propulsion Labs
and we're here to help.
JASON SANMIYA: That's
our logo, by the way.
So what do we do?
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN: So
we make C++ game development
libraries.
JASON SANMIYA: These
libraries are cross-platform,
so they work on Android,
iOS, Windows, Mac, Linux,
probably on consoles,
but they're not
part of our test suites.
In some cases they
work on the web too.
They're all open source.
They're all on GitHub right now.
You can go download
them if you like.
WOUTER VAN
OORTMERSSEN: And we've
created them both for external
developers, game developers,
and also for an internal
users at Google.
JASON SANMIYA: That's right.
They're all independent
libraries as well.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN: But
let's stop for a second here.
Probably people have the
question, why libraries?
Most people will have an
existing engine, right?
JASON SANMIYA: So from what
we've seen, more than half
of game developers are
actually using a custom engine.
So there's a lot
of game developers
that don't want to buy
into monolithic third party
technology.
So by providing
separate libraries,
we allow game developers to
adopt our technology piecemeal.
They can just use
whatever they need
and fit it with what
they already have.
And even if they are using
a third party engine,
if there's something out
there that they like,
they can just grab that and
jury rig it into their engine
as well.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN: Great.
So let's talk about
these libraries
and how they can help you
make more efficient games.
JASON SANMIYA: OK, excellent.
Let's start at the bottom.
Wouter, how do we store stuff?
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
Well, for that
we have FlatBuffers, which
is our serialization library.
It works for games and it
works for anything, really.
As you all know,
serialization is
about how we load,
store, and encode stuff.
And that is very vital for
a memory efficient game.
Now what is special
about FlatBuffers
is that it is a format
that works equally
well on disk and in memory,
so you don't actually
have to unpack it.
JASON SANMIYA: Wow.
WOUTER VAN
OORTMERSSEN: Nice one.
So this saves on parsing time.
It means you don't have any
object allocation whatsoever.
It generally
reduces memory usage
and it is more cache efficient.
So what I want to say
is if your project, game
or not-- if it uses
JSON or protocol
buffers or some other
serialization solution,
you can probably benefit
from using FlatBuffers.
JASON SANMIYA: Let
me interrupt there.
Interesting fact that
JSON format is so amazing,
they named it after me.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
That is not true.
JASON SANMIYA: It's not true.
WOUTER VAN
OORTMERSSEN: But it is
a good idea, which is
why FlatBuffers first
has JSON parsing built in.
JASON SANMIYA: Right.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
Yes, languages.
So we originally designed
FlatBuffers for C++ and game
development.
But we also have support for
your favorite programming
language, assuming your favorite
programming language is one
of C, C++, Java, C#, Go,
Python, JavaScript, PHP, Swift,
et cetera.
And that's just in case that
your tools or servers are
written in something
other than C++.
JASON SANMIYA: And sometimes
that makes a lot of sense.
WOUTER VAN
OORTMERSSEN: Sometimes.
OK.
You know what's also fundamental
is all this math that games
use.
How do we deal with that?
JASON SANMIYA: We have
a library called MathFu,
and it implements a lot of
common geometry functions,
and it's designed to
be simple and fast.
So by geometry we mean the
math on vectors and matrices,
usually two, three, four,
dimensions, sometimes more.
Rendering, physics,
animation, AI, they all
use this kind of math, anything
that deals with physical space
and calculations within it.
Of course, there is other
open source math libraries
out there, some of them very
good, like Eigen and TLM.
But we wanted one
that was very simple
and focused on the math
that was required for games,
and not necessarily, say,
for scientific applications,
like Eigen is very good at.
We also wanted to
make a library that
was extremely fast, because
it's the foundation for all
of our other libraries.
So we spent a lot of
time benchmarking MathFu
and optimizing it
where appropriate.
For example, many
of the functions
use Symbian
instructions, especially
the matrix operations.
So this is like SSE instructions
and NEON instructions.
These leverage the vector
processing unit on the chips.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
I think you're
losing the audience, Jason.
JASON SANMIYA: Am I really?
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN: Yeah.
Technical.
JASON SANMIYA:
Anyway, it's fast.
So we have data and math.
Wouter, what do we need next?
WOUTER VAN
OORTMERSSEN: So FPLBase
is our lowest level
game library that we
use for rendering, inputs,
loading resources, things
like shaders, meshes,
textures, anything
that you need to get a
game on screen, basically.
It also has useful
functionality for dealing
with input devices and VR.
It also has threaded
resource loading.
FPLBase was intended
as a way to go
from an empty project
to drawing something
on screen as fast as possible
with as little code as
possible.
So it has all the
minimal functionality
that you typically
don't get when you
work on top of raw open gel.
Now it's on purpose not
meant to be an engine.
It's not dictating how your
game should be structured
or anything like that.
It's just meant to be simple
and easy and quick to get going.
So it works on all platforms,
mobile and desktop,
thanks to SDL.
JASON SANMIYA: SDL is the
simple direct media layer.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
And other FPL libraries
may be used on top of it.
So now that we
can render things,
what's the next thing to
make our games come to life?
JASON SANMIYA: So
animation, I think,
is a really great way to
bring your games to life.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
You would say that.
JASON SANMIYA: And Motive
is our animation system.
It's a really great way to
bring character and charm
to your games.
Animation is kind of
intimidating to a lot
of developers.
There's just a lot of ways to
move something from point A
to point B. And
some of them have
a lot of feeling and intent,
but others just kind of look
robotic.
So the goal of Motive is to make
it easy to animate everything
smooth and intensely.
So to do this, we made
the runtime extremely fast
because often there's
a lot in your scene
that needs to be animated.
It computes values in bulk
with the Symbian instructions
I was talking about.
The memory format is
also very compact,
and this helps with the memory
bandwidth limitations that's
intrinsic to mobile devices.
With Motive you can
drive animations
with pre-authored
splines, or you can also
drive it procedurally
to, say, naturally follow
a moving target.
OK, so now we're
going to show you
one of our sample
games, Pie Noon,
to give you an idea of
how simple motion can
help bring a game to life.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
JASON SANMIYA: OK.
So most of the animation in Pie
Noon is actually procedural.
But in our next game, Zushi, we
support fully-rigged character
animation.
So the dapper crocodile
here will do a little jig
when you feed him a piece of
sushi, as you would expect.
And the jig animation is created
using third party animation
authoring tools like
Maya or Blender,
and it's brought into our
game via an animation pipeline
that we've written.
So we'll show you a
video of Zushi in a bit.
OK, Wouter, so we've
got this game animated.
How do we communicate
with the user?
Well for that we have FlatUI.
So FlatUI is an
immediate mode UI library
that's meant to make
it simple, easy,
and efficient to add menus,
HUDs, and other elements
to your game.
So let's talk a little bit
about what this immediate mode
thing means.
It means that rather than
constructing your UI using
objects and callbacks
and things like that,
you actually construct
UI by function calls
that you create your
UI every frame again.
Now that has a whole
bunch of advantages.
For example, first of
all there's less code.
There's less set of work
to do, and simple UIs
are pretty simple to get going.
It's much easier to
do than dynamic UI
because if you don't call
a particular UI snippet,
it does not appear on screen.
So there is no adding and
removing of objects or anything
like that needs to happen.
It also means that
your UI is always
consistent with your game
state because you actually
can't forget to set
some state on your UI.
Event handling is all local,
so it's right there in place
when you're constructing
your UI and you
have the data right there.
So there's no
callbacks happening
that might execute on
a different context
or something like that.
And it's very easy to
make custom UI elements
because you can just
combine multiple function
calls into one.
For example, here's
a contrived example
in the slide where we
have two UI elements
like a label and a button.
And as you can see, they're
just function calls.
The event handling is
just an if then statement.
And for the state
that we're managing,
we can just use
any variable that
happens to be the scope over
here, making it pretty simple.
Now FlatUI has a couple of
additional cool features.
So first of all, has very robust
front rendering that is Unicode
internationalization aware.
It generally uses
amazingly little memory.
Beyond any textures and
fonts that you load,
it pretty much uses no memory.
JASON SANMIYA: That's kind of
a theme you're seeing here.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN: Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
Importantly, it can
render things into 3D.
If you're doing
VR, for example, it
does automatic
layout of everything
using virtual sizes, which
means that your UIs look great
on any screen.
And it doesn't dictate a style.
If you can render it, it
can be restyled, basically.
So Jason, you already
spoke about animation.
What else can you give us
that makes games come alive?
JASON SANMIYA: One of
our first libraries,
and one of the more popular,
is a liquid physics simulator
called Liquid Fun.
Liquid Fun is a drop in
extension for the popular box
2D physics engine.
It's a really simple way to add
2D liquid, gas, and particle
effects to your game.
The runtime algorithm
is kind of clever,
and it's extremely efficient.
So you'd probably be surprised
at how much complicated motion
it can create.
One of our other sample
games we'll show you
here is called
Liquid Fun Paints.
We'll just show you the
beginning of this trailer
so you get a sense for
what the library does.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
JASON SANMIYA: OK.
So that's the idea.
That's a really fun app you can
also find in the Play Store.
A lot of kids love
it, like Wouter.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
Thanks, Jason.
So our next library is PinDrop,
which is our audio solution.
So what's special
about PinDrop is
that it goes beyond
just mere audio mixing.
For example, it handles
prioritization and attenuation.
That means that if
you have a game scene
and suddenly there's
a lot of events,
a lot of gameplay events
triggering a lot of sounds,
that the system
will automatically
take care of making that into a
coherent audio picture for you,
basically.
It also allows you to
group and selectively
override relative importance
of whole groups of sounds.
For example, if you want to
make sure that voiceovers get
heard and things like that.
Not unimportantly,
it's very data-driven,
which means that people
that author the audio don't
need to do any programming.
It's pretty cool.
JASON SANMIYA: Corgi is our
entity component system.
Now entity component
systems have
emerged as a popular
programming paradigm in games.
So they allow you to
associate component behaviors
with entities in the scene.
For example, suppose I could
add an animation component
to a dog entity, and this would
allow the dog to roll over.
Or we could add an audio
component to the dog,
and that would allow
the dog to bark.
And instead of storing the
roll over and barking data
with the dog entity,
we instead group
all the animation data in one
spot, and all the audio data
in another spot,
and this allows you
to have significantly
better memory performance
when you're operating on data in
bulk, as you have to in games.
So note the contrast here
between object oriented
programming and component
oriented programming.
So the behaviors
and the data are
stored with the entity in
object oriented programming.
So entity component systems,
there's nothing new.
If you're making a game
you probably have your own.
So what we've done with Corgi
is simply package and document
well the one that we wrote,
and put it up on GitHub
for you to use if you like.
Corgi, by the way, stands for
Component Organized Reusable
Game Interface.
But mostly we chose the
name because of this guy.
He's kind of our unofficial
project manager on FPL.
I mean, you can't say
no to those eyes, right?
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN: So
SceneLab is our scene editor.
SceneLab kind of takes all these
previous libraries together,
so it uses Corgi for the
objects that it edits,
uses FlatBuffers for all
of its data, of course,
and it uses FlatUI.
The cool thing about SceneLab is
that it's so data-driven and so
configurable that if you pass
it different kinds of object
definitions, it will
automatically allow
you to edit different things.
So it's very easy to slot
into a different game
and have an editor
specifically for that game.
JASON SANMIYA: Our last
library is called BreadBoard.
It's an event system that
allows you to connect
disparate systems using data.
So every game has
different systems
like audio, AI, and the UI.
And you want to keep
these systems separate so
that they don't have to make
function calls into each other.
Otherwise you end up
with spaghetti code.
So BreadBoard lets you do this.
For example, you could
take a football event
from the animation system
and route that over
to the audio system, which would
then play a stepping sound.
And the two systems,
they don't need
to be connected
with function calls.
BreadBoard also supports
some arbitrary logic
nodes so you can route
events a little bit more
cleverly if you like.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN: Wow.
Look at all those animals.
JASON SANMIYA: So you
knew this was coming.
This is where we take a look
at Zushi, our latest game.
And in Zushi you float down
a mystic river feeding sushi
to well-dressed animal patrons.
It's a 3D game.
It runs in VR at 60
frames per second.
So that's pretty
high performance.
Even though it's
a few characters
on the screen the game
play is very simple,
it's actually technically
a high performance game.
And everything in the
world is animated.
It has a UI, audio,
a level editor.
So even though it's
a very simple game,
the technology
stack has everything
that you would need to make
your own high performance
VR or 3D game.
And the technology
stack in Zushi
is the libraries that we
just described to you.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
You can do it.
JASON SANMIYA: There we go
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
JASON SANMIYA: OK.
So all the data in that game
is stored in FlatBuffers.
It's edited in SceneLab.
And using SceneLab, we can
also add corgi components
to all the entities.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
And FPLBase
is used to render everything
for input and resource loading.
JASON SANMIYA: Motive animates
all of the motion in the scene.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
And FlatUI shows the menus.
JASON SANMIYA: PinDrop plays
the music and sound effects.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN:
And finally, BreadBoard
connects all the
components together
and allows us to define a game
flow in data, like Jason said.
JASON SANMIYA: It's worth
noting that all the sample
games that we showed you
today are also open source,
so you can go to GitHub,
download them, and use them
to prototype your own ideas.
In fact, the Social
Good team here at Google
has done just that.
This is the team that powers the
donations through google.org.
And they also drove the
newly launched donations card
on YouTube.
They're doing a
lot of good stuff.
So what they did
with Pie Noon is
to create a prototype of
their new donations API.
This is an API that lets
users make in-app donations,
and then it'll
automatically process
the payments and the billing.
There's no fees.
There's no spam
sent to the users.
And most importantly, it has the
ability for you, the developer,
to support any
US-based nonprofit.
So basically you're
encouraging gamers
to support real world
causes from within the game.
I think it's a
pretty exciting API,
and you should check out
their work at this link here.
And speaking of links--
WOUTER VAN
OORTMERSSEN: All right.
So if you want to play around
with any of the technologies
that you've seen so far,
this is our developer site.
JASON SANMIYA: Yep.
All these links and links
to all the libraries
are in the space for
this talk as well.
So thanks for listening.
We hope you're excited to
create high performance games.
And we hope that our technology
can help you with that.
WOUTER VAN OORTMERSSEN: So
we're going to have a Q&A now.
And if you want to talk to
me and Jason afterwards,
come find us.
We're here to help.
[MUSIC PLAYING]